what is up everyone oh yeah there's that
good energy
how you guys doing yeah the guy at the
back is really quite yeah are you guys
excited yeah
talk about moonshots talk about
philanthropy talk about the importance
of really executing these big-picture
visions into our world it's gonna be
able yeah a lot of fun we're really
excited and very grateful to have
intervene here all right this is
simulation how many of you guys have
been a simulation before you have little
applause little applause for those have
been okay okay how about those that have
not whose first time is it yeah this
good applause for you yeah it's just
possible is having good it's like 50/50
that's good all right so simulation is
reversing the public intellectual and
inspiring you to build the future we do
so through a multidisciplinary daily
show and live event series and we're
gonna scale these multidisciplinary
events to sports stadiums so if twenty
two football players can do it so can
50,000 curious intellectuals so let's
get it all the way up there all right so
that's a little bit about us we are at
work wise work wise is an amazing space
and you guys definitely yes it's a
beautiful space this is Richard one of
the co-founders you will be hearing just
a very quick bit from Richard about the
importance of work-wise I sorry I asked
oh so I want to start off really by just
welcoming you all here for this evening
and I want to thank Alan and Ben
obviously and for the team for bringing
an event like this to our space I
particularly enjoy what stimmt
simulations do for me it's all about the
deep conversation about asking the
questions sometimes the complicated ones
and the challenging and trying to find
answers and change the world we all live
in I find it really relevant because it
resonates with me about why I wanted to
build work-wise yeah it's a co-working
space we've got offices and desks and
rooms and phone rooms and meeting rooms
but for me it's much more than that we
know that what people
won't need and respond to in the world
of work is changing massively we know
that understanding people each other
what we need we know that that's the key
to us building a community that really
succeeds when we're we ask the questions
where we seek answers on how we can all
work better be better help each other
more we want to challenge the accepted
build a new way of working and change
how people think about the workplace
yeah it's a space it's got walls and
windows and ceilings and aircon but it's
a community first a real community and
when we're we're lucky enough to host an
evening like tonight where conversations
challenges all where the answers empower
every single one of us and that's what
we're trying to do here at work wise so
all that remains to say is welcome all
to the space thank you as always thanks
have a great evening everybody we hope
to see you here soon yes
workwise rocks definitely check them out
workwise comm wer q w is e comm check
them out definitely the future
definitely the future of working
together we all know that whatever is
coming with artificial intelligence and
the change in the workflows is
definitely really profound shift and
what's going to happen so let's get
ready for it we asked fully
thought-provoking questions we have a
really great guest tonight you know
Naveen as the man of Moon expressed a
man of AI ohm the man of the XPrize just
a man that is just dreaming big and
helping other people dream big and
execute let's give a big round of
applause for Naveen Jane thanks Allen
[Applause]
thank you for coming on to the show
awesome I'm looking forward to it
yeah you you're just like you're the man
of moonshot for you like I love that and
you're wrote a book about it now that's
coming out look yeah that's got moon
shots yeah yeah it would be a very
exciting way to inspire more people to
really get this this picture of what's
of why we are you know such a limited
amount of time we have 80 years on this
damn planet and it's amazing place but
we only have 80 years it's so short so
what better to do with our time than to
dream the absolute biggest and go and
execute that big dream into the world
yes so tell us about that feeling for
you well first of all I mean every one
of us irrespective how much I want to
live forever we still have a finite time
on this planet and that means what is it
that we can do what are we willing to
dedicate our lives to that will be
meaningful and to me it really comes
down to is what is it that you want to
do when you wake up in the morning if
any one of you I don't care what thing
you're doing if you don't jump out of
the bed at 4 a.m. and not have to put a
snooze button you're doing something
wrong with your life right you have to
be able to figure out what are you
willing to die for and then live for it
what is it that if you had everything in
life whether it is billions of dollars
whether it is family whatever you care
about if you had everything what would
you do and if you do that today
we'll get you everything that you always
wanted you go backward
you never ever focus on the end goal
every one of the person who starts a
company simply to make money will never
get it making money is like having an
orgasm if you focus on it you never get
it you just have to enjoy the process
right so if you enjoy the process you
will get it but if you keep thinking you
wanted you want and you want and you
never get it right so that's it we have
our first it's first experience here
never think about it but fact is that's
you know you have to focus on what you
really love and the only way you know
what you really love is to do the things
that you would do when you don't need
anything right so this is I am now on my
seventh company there's no reason for me
at this MA at this age for me to be
doing anything other than chilling on
someone Island right and to me I am
doing this because this is what I call
retirement I am fully retired I only do
things that I absolutely love there is
not a thing if it is not what you know I
don't wake up in the morning and get it
started about I still have time to leave
and time to do something else it has to
be something where you never think twice
I never spent 30 seconds in the bed I
jump out of the bed thinking what an
amazing life what an amazing life we are
living and that has to be every one of
us in this room if you don't believe
you're living that life where you wake
up in the morning when someone says how
are you you don't say fine you said one
[ __ ] amazing day right and that's
what needs to be every day from the time
you wake up the time you hit the pillow
it has to be that amazingly when you say
I am blessed
naveen you are blessed in many ways
you've worked very hard to become
blessed and a lot of people are still
struggling and that struggle makes it
really difficult for them to come up
with moonshots and jump out of bed in
the morning go excuse me how do you
envision a society that enables people
to go for their moonshots it's not
easier actually than it sounds the
people who come from a I would say a
background where they have resources
they tend to fall in love with those
resources and they tend to not ever want
to lose them when you come from nothing
you have nothing to lose
every time I wonder and saying what is
that worst thing that can happen to me
don't have food to eat don't have place
to stay been there done that there's
nothing you can tell me that scares me
anymore
what scares me is living a life that I
don't enjoy that scares the hell out of
me is that what if some day I am doing
things I just didn't enjoy I see that is
the right I give everyone I know you
have time to put a bullet through my
head I'm done I'm a parasite on society
right the day I am taking more from the
society that I'm giving back I'm a
parasite that's a definition of a
parasite right if you find someone who
has time to change the small ball and a
golf course they have lived they are out
lived their life they should be the one
someone should say let me take you out
of your misery let me put you to pasture
because they have really if they have
time to change a small ball if that's
what their life is all about playing
golf they're zombies they should be
living life hey Naveen how about this
one okay so you're totally right that
when we're in lower socioeconomic status
we have less to lose so it is marked in
a census that's part of it but at the
same time that you can potentially be
further away from these information
superhighways that make it easier for
you to achieve your goals that like
people that have resources do so let me
tell you I mean obviously as most of you
probably who and
mean that know that I came from very
humble background came you know didn't
have food to eat didn't have place to
stay came to the United States with $5
didn t speak the language where were you
I was in India we're in it and we had no
place so we moved from village to
village so we had no place we call home
but interesting thing is when I came
here it was never about money
it was simply about doing something
absolutely amazing and I can tell you
today I find it so much easier to raise
money or to do things that are ambitious
the things that will fundamentally
change the trajectory of how humanity is
going to live then to do something
another iPhone app right I tell you that
if you want to go do something and you
think you have nothing the best way to
do that is to tell someone what if you
could create a world and you post you
pitch you can imagine that world and all
you have to do is not tell them what you
do tell them what the world would look
like when that work is done so every
single time I start a company I start
with a simple visualization of what is
it that word would look like if I am
successful so while the current company
that I am working on his company called
my own and it says imagine living in a
world where illness is optional and
before we get to know I'm just I'm
simply saying okay I'm just going to
come down at a point is that that was
the statement we did
what if illness could be elective what
if illness was a choice and that was the
theme people don't see now all they can
see is tell me how but that is the
vision no one can argue is worth going
after every company you start what is
that vision that you have that people
say I want to be part of that and I'm
gonna tell you some amazing story of
starting this company so as you will
know that I am NOT a doctor I am NOT a
sign
naveen you're gonna tell about starting
volume I'm gonna just talk about
starting a company or starting a company
yeah okay just a quick probably quick
prior to that is this sort of mentality
of entrepreneurs
being future leaders okay so yeah you
specifically you've made it clear the
government's no this is entrepreneurs
are the next iterations of the world
builders and then within your story as
well yeah so I think what Ellen is
referring to is that I have been really
in terms of thinking about how
entrepreneurs are going to be the next
superpower I believe the problems that
used to be the domain of nation-states
are going to now be solved by
entrepreneurs so if you go back and look
at what is it that we expected the
nation-states to do what is it that was
going to space looking at healthcare
looking at education looking at creating
you know safety looking at things like
water and we culture food and those were
the things you relied on nation-states
and for the simple reason because we
believed the individuals are not capable
of solving those problems a small group
of people are not capable of solving
this problem and that is fundamental
change we are living in the most
innovative time in the human history we
are you and I in a small group of people
simply believing what is possible can
change the trajectory of how humanity is
going to live you look at today my other
company is a moon express that is the
only company in the universe that has
permission to leave Earth orbit despite
what you may hear from my friend at Elon
or Richard or Jeff none of them can
leave the Earth orbit they all is stuck
in the low Earth orbit so someday they
got to get ambitious they can talk all
they were
right they can't leave at all but right
now in fact not only we can leave Earth
orbit we are the first company that has
permission to land on any celestial body
what engine see does one have to go and
get this application that will answer it
there is no such agency so when we were
going to go and say we are going to go
to the moon we went to every
three-letter agency that you can
possibly imagine
he went to NSA they went to CIA we went
to DoD in Amman to do a we went to ever
yeah FAA we went to every three-letter
agency and everyone told us are you
killing us I can give you hundred
reasons why we will never allow that and
even if you were to satisfy every one of
our concern all I can say is don't say
no but I can't say yes because it's not
in our Charter there is no place any
department that says come here for
mission approval to the mission to the
moon
there is no department so how do you do
that and that is the story of being an
entrepreneur all I'm trying to say is
that when we land on the moon next year
not only we become the first private
company we symbolically become then
fourth superpower to ever landed on the
moon
how do you become that fourth superpower
simply by doing things that no other
nation is paid or anyone else has done
now same thing is going to happen in
every industry and I'm going to tell you
more specifically how one of them is
like health care health care is not
going to be solved by Obama care or
Trump care or even put him care it's not
gonna be solved by then he is going to
be solved by some entrepreneur saying
enough is enough
and we're going to go do that no
different than what happened in the
energy or electric vehicle alone as you
know as much as you love him or hate him
you got to admire he's got a duck
the guy has balls of steel right no one
told him that no car come no automotive
company has been created in the last 50
years and you want to create a left
electric car company you're crazy he
went and did that today is the market
cap higher than the GM and food how did
that happen one man can change that how
are you going to find the batteries I'm
going to build the biggest damn Giga
factory that can be built the point was
one single person's vision can change
the way we live it is today how do you
create abundance of energy how do you
create abundance of food how do you
create abundance of water first the
scarcity mean what says the idea is even
your mindset how do you change your
mindset from thinking about scarcity to
thinking about abundance the only reason
we value anything is because we believe
those things are finite in resources if
something is finite they have value
something that is in finite or an
abundance has no value we fight over
things because we believe if they are
finite if someone else has it I can't
have it there is only limited quantities
and that's why we fight over
we fight over land we fight over water
we fight over energy all the wars are
fought over all those things now imagine
we're living on a planet where every 90
minutes more energy more solar energy
falls on this planet every 90 minute
then we use in the whole year simply a
matter of conversion every child Space
Station orbits every single time think
about you know every 90 minutes a space
station like it is simply a matter of
conversion now go back and look at what
happened in the past the most precious
metal on earth used to be aluminum it
was so rare because we never fought
never found in the pure form
it was always found in the fore
a bauxite and to extract aluminium from
bauxite used to be extremely expensive
so expensive that when Napoleon wanted
to show his wealth to the King of Siam
he served him with the aluminium platter
to show that how rich he is in fact so
much so that tip of the Washington
Monument in Washington DC is not
platinum is aluminium it was done to
show the British errs we have arrived
we are the rich country we can put on
the top the aluminium that nobody can
afford we throw it away today why is
that
a technology called electrolysis came
about that changed that what is that
electrolysis of the solar power that
will change the efficiency from 22
percent 25 percent to 35 percent it does
all we did we will have abundance of
free energy and people say wow it
doesn't matter people will always fight
over resources because humans are greedy
humans always fight it doesn't matter
how much you have they want more until
you remind people what is it that we
don't fight over here 70 thousand of us
can sit in a stadium and never tell
someone hey move
you're taking my air my oxygen we all
can enjoy why because inherently we
believe it is abundant it is free it
democratized
demonetized is completely free for
everyone what if the energy was the next
air it is free and when you have the
abundance of free energy you can have
abundance of free fresh water the
dirtiest water in Africa can be
distilled and you have fresh clean water
just that what if we have abundance of
food free food what would that world
look like why do we believe today the
land is only the land we live in today
why can't we live on any place we want
whether it is Moon or Mars or tighten or
Europa and people say oh wait a for a
second here that is impossible don't you
oh they have high radiation what
protects humans on earth is because we
have atmosphere it protects from all the
radiation and you see that's right
however why do you believe the humans
can be radiation resistant that is just
not possible now think about it for a
second we find bacteria growing in
radioactive nuclear waste the highest
radiation possible and the organisms
have not nature has not only figured out
how to protect its DNA from radiation
it has also figured out how to use the
radiation as a source of energy now
imagine if we can take a genetic
material the genes from these bacteria
in vivo use CRISPR to modify ourselves
not only we become radiation resistant
we also don't need to eat food anymore
in the evening you hold the hand of your
honey and if you want to go out and get
some radiation and that's your food and
the food simply becomes something so
shall we do right it's just like I mean
today you know hate to say but sex used
to be only for procreation today we only
use it for social purposes right food
can be the same thing we only use food
just because we want to be social not
because you need to eat food for energy
energy can be come from any number of
other sources whether it is radiation or
it could be a number of others other
ways we can get the energy that we body
needs we can modify our human body to do
that and we can still be flash people
talk about gravity again it may we may
look different because every time you
want low gravity you don't need all the
bone mass to keep your structure alive
and that we may walk to live on low
gravity the point really is there is
nothing that you can't solve for the
first time we have the technology at our
disposal to be able to solve many of the
problems the reason the people don't
able to people don't solve problem is
most of the time people tend to get
stuck at solving a problem that simply
is the symptom not the root cause so let
me give you an example and then yeah and
then I'm gonna then I'm gonna move on to
the next subject look at people talk
about having lack of fresh water and
people say that's one of the biggest
problems facing humanity is lack of
fresh water and they want to figure out
how to create more water and people say
can we create some type of nano filters
that can take the desalination I go take
a dirty water and filter through the
things that will kill the viruses and
bacteria and you'll be able to do that
until you realize that majority of the
fresh water is actually used in
agriculture and you say ah all I have to
do is solve the agriculture problem can
we use aquaponic agriculture aeroponic
agriculture or even use the seeds that
are lightly modified so they can use the
lightly salted water and I have
abundance of fresh water and now I have
solved a real problem until you realize
that majority of the agriculture is
actually used for feeding the cattles
and all I have to do now is solve the
problem of people eating meat and what
if we can create meat using stem cell
take a stem cell of a cow and simply
grow the muscle tissues instead of going
any other tissue that we don't eat and
suddenly a freshwater problem really
becomes a synthetic biology problem
because you understand what is the root
cause rather than what the symptom is
and you can do the by level at every
technology you look at self-driving car
it is pretty obvious how self-driving
car is going to disrupt automotive
industry you may not need to own a car
because it'll be available to you
whenever you need it today you need a
Prius because you're going too far or
next a unit if Ferrari because you want
to be able to impress your girlfriend
and it's there but that is just the
primary industry that's got disrupted
what people don't realize is secondary
and tertiary industries that are going
to be disrupted with a single technology
if you have a self-driving car that has
all the sensors
they always talk into each other you can
drive the cars much closer to each other
than humans can ever do that means you
don't need to build as many roads what
happens to the construction industries
the caterpillars of the world
same reason now if you don't have to
have the car parked right where next to
where you work what happens to all the
parking garages in the parking lots can
they become the affordable housing
certainly you have the real estate
industry that's going to be disrupted if
these cars are not getting into
accidents what happens to the auto
insurance if people are not dying in the
auto what happens to the life insurance
industry and you can go on and on and on
and you can start to see that how single
technology can disrupt tens of
industries there are secondary and
tertiary and I can give me examples of
almost every technology how that is
gonna impact many of these industries
that way of viewing the world is crucial
first of all the identifying roots of
problems and then also kind of the way
that the solute these new innovations of
the like you said secondary tertiary
ways they impact society because if you
take and look at a lot of the kids that
are being born and raised into the world
what are we teaching them in the
education system are they learning about
artificial intelligence are they
learning about biotechnology they're
learning about these exponential
technologies that are revolutionizing
our world because these are the ways to
prepare the children for the future
naveen maybe a question before we
continue on to talk about education yeah
I want to hear your thoughts about this
because do you what you obviously with
XPrize is working on a couple projects
related to education especially the one
that you were teaching me about today
about literacy that one's huge in math
and language and science literacy but in
just 18 months how do you teach someone
that doesn't know anything but how about
just in general from a perspective of
education do you are you a are you a man
that thinks that there are some sort of
foundational principles that every child
should should understand and learn as
their birthday to the world so you know
look at education and healthcare and
spend time on both of them for just
briefly here so in both cases it is
pretty obvious that people believe that
you know at our education system and our
healthcare system is broken it's just
not working it turns out that neither of
the system is actually broken they both
doing exactly what they were designed to
do so our education system was designed
to teach us his skills and those are
skills we could use for rest of our life
in the industrial era and life was
wonderful
you needed five thousand people in
machinists you need ten thousand
accountants we need twenty thousand
people who knew this and life was
wonderful in the world of exponential
technologies it doesn't matter what is
kill you learn by the time you graduate
that is skill has become obsolete then
what is that education system is
supposed to do what it has to rethink
not that the education system is somehow
broken it needs to be reimagined and
rethought how do we teach learning to
learn learning to collaborate no longer
about having expertise in a subject
because the problems don't tend to be
unit disciplinary problems a
multidisciplinary then you have to teach
kids multi disciplines in today's
education system it is all about an
individual so if I have a problem and if
I say hey Allen what do you think is the
right answer in today's education system
we call that cheating so if I go to him
and say hey Ellen here is a problem what
do you think is the answer oh you're
cheating in work we call it a teamwork
right collaboration and how do you teach
that so the interesting thing is all the
things we can now figure out what the
new problem is and what the new
solutions are it's not that somehow the
old thing is broken the same way of
looking at it is if you look at your
grandpa and many of the people probably
don't remember the flip phones do you
remember the flip old Motorola flip
phone right if you grandpa using that
and you said grandpa your phone is
broken he's gonna say what part of it's
broken it's doing what it was designed
to do i press dial and it dials the
phone but can't find doesn't play Angry
Bird well it wasn't designed to play
anybody right so point is it's not the
things is broken it just has a different
purpose now same thing is true for
health care and I'm before I go there I
just wanted to you know spend one more
minute on this education thing one of
the in entrepreneurship
the reason lot of the entrepreneurs are
afraid to do something is because they
believe they don't know much about that
subject right so I say hey I can how can
I go out and start a company in AI I
know nothing about AI how am I going to
start a company in healthcare I know
nothing about human biology and it turns
out when you are an expert on any field
you are more or less useless in that
field and here's why I say useless if
you are an expert the best you can do is
to make an incremental improvement into
what you know if if you are an expert
you can make a 10 something 10% better
than what anyone else has done but if
you want to change something 10 times or
100 times you have to be a non expert
and it's not about thinking outside the
box it's about thinking in a completely
different box applying the knowledge of
one industry in two completely different
industry and that's how you
fundamentally change that industry when
I came to you know and my other company
every company by the way I've done no
two companies have ever been in the same
industry I always felt that once I've
gotten one company right I don't want to
do the same thing you see I'm industry
because I'll just be better than someone
else I won't be able to disrupt it so
when I started my company in the in the
aerospace I didn't even know I think
about in fact the first time I remember
we said you know I said how do you go to
the moon every time I look at it's keeps
moving
I mean you go to some place that keeps
moving
and they say well there is orbital
dynamics and they're teaching me all
that I said that sounds pretty
interesting actually now how do we go
there and they all say what is you know
you have to build this big massive
rocket that can go to the moon I come
from the software world and I said why
do you have to run a monolithic code why
can't you write modular it's tough one
thing goes here and the second thing
takes over and you go there and the
first thing they see what because that
will never work that's why you do it
this way and I asked him why do you
think it won't work and the thing they
say are you rocket scientists I said I'm
not but you are why don't you tell me
and they start explaining and as they're
explaining in this you know you know it
might work
and I say keep explaining tell me why it
might work by that an hour later they
say holy [ __ ] that's a bright idea it's
a bright idea because they never ever
thought this could be done now imagine
the first time when we landed in the
moon it cost us a billion dollars our
cost of going to the moon now is going
to be under 10 million dollars you tell
us a bit about how we can get there so
we basically decided that we don't need
to have a big rocket what if we simply
take a smallest possible rocket that
goes to the low Earth orbit and by the
way you can now buy them on the website
you can go to rocket lab calm and say
buy a rocket put in the shopping cart
and it says 5 million dollars and you
put we put 5 of them on the shopping
cart and we call the CEOs look at the
shopping cart that's Co 5 of them how
much discount do you think we can get
right and we got them for 3.75 right my
point is you can pocket
[Laughter]
that's what the world we live in now we
bought a rocket for four million dollars
and we build a lender and a whole cost
and the lender everybody thought you
want to custom this and the custom that
how are you going to detect where you
are on the space you need these fancy
cameras to be able to know where you are
and to be able to compare them you know
what do we do about GoPros and we took
the casing of the thing out and we put
the new casing change the GoPro right it
was every single sensor to do the lidar
to essentially know how fast you're
going and how far away from your the
moon surface what you do is you shoot
the laser down and you look the thing
back up and you know where you how far
you are and how fast you're going when
we started the company they told us it's
gonna cost a million dollars and we
bought them now for under $500 because
these are the same sensor they use them
in the self-driving cars my point is all
the sensors that are needed to land on
the moon are the ones that are on our
iPhone they're on self-driving cars
so all these exponential technologies
are making all these things cheaper it's
smaller and lighter so everything that
makes the iPhone thinner and cheaper and
more powerful is exactly what allows us
to go to the moon faster cheaper better
right and those are you point to such a
crucial thing also which is the question
that you asked why does it have to be
this way and if people would just reply
to the question with an open mind and
say let's explore that then you can get
to new innovations and creations rather
than just the close-minded perspective
and that is the interesting point and
part of it is two parts one is being
intellectually curious and other part is
being dumb enough to ask if you are an
expert and you tell seriously if you are
a molecular biologist and you start
asking a question which is really basic
people are going to look at you and say
huh but which university did you get the
degree from being an immigrant a village
boy nobody ever questions is hey I'm a
village boy what do I know why don't you
explain this to me
right and when you start asking them
really really basic questions it's
suddenly you start to rethink and
reimagine so one of the things that also
about education up gonna mention is that
like the good old question of who are
you or Who am I
I'll come back to that too let's also
make sure you two very almost ever River
we'll have some Q&A as well you know
okay we'll get to that then so what I
was trying to say was that today
whether you are a teacher or you are a
parent the thing you always struggle
with is I can only take you to the water
I cannot make you drink I can only do so
much I just can't do any further and the
reason is that is the wrong question to
us and that's a rough wrong problem to
solve what if my job is not to take you
to the water or make you drink what if
my job is simply to make you thirsty
what if I make me thirsty not only you
will find your own water and you will be
drinking what is the thirst that you can
create in humans is called intellectual
curiosity once you give that
intellectual curiosity to your children
rest of their life they are set they are
looking for water all the time they're
drinking that water all the time because
you keep telling them what if I love
that insatiable curiosity that appetite
what if and that what if so the things
that I always always tell our children
was asked what if that was possible what
would that world look like and use the
word imagine there is no more powerful
word if you are ever looking to raise
money or making a pitch don't start with
anything you do this is the only word
that takes away all preconceived ideas
that people have all I have to say is
imagine and your mind is wide open right
now to anything I want to tell you to
imagine you're ready for it
it blanks out your space for you to
create a new space imagine a world where
50,000 curious electric what
that is right that is the beauty and the
thing has to be something people can
visualize what you can say is imagine a
company that is big that is really
powerful that it really has biggest
market share and this and people are
thinking I don't know how to imagine
that right it has to be a picture you
can imagine visualize let me tell you
the difference is Martin Luther King
what did he says he didn't say I want a
racially imagine the racial equality and
I can't imagine that he said imagine a
white boy holding the hand of a black
girl walking together anybody can
imagine that that is the visualization
on talking about it so when I say
imagine a world where no one is sick no
one is suffering that's the world you
can see you that would be an amazing
world and the only question you can ask
me after that is I love it how do we get
there this was a blast we did an
unboxing video of volume it was very
funny when I opened up the little how
many of you guys have done bio in here
maybe my applause has anyone done biome
yet well you know there's a there's a
discount used code simulation you can
get a discount
$100 off but this is so interesting
because when you open it up there's
actually a very fun experience which is
you get to strap no no before you do
what it did that is this does your honor
okay Ellen you're the expert at it so
why don't you tell me what oh no I'm not
oh you're the earth oh there is a very
hilarious part of this which is that you
get to take a sample of your poop and
that is that is a really great way of
understanding what's going on inside
your microbiome and then you get
insights from violent okay so
if you think about what makes us human
what makes us human is not the genes
that we get from our mom and dad which
is what we always thought our DNA is
what makes us human it's very
interesting that coming from completely
outside the things that completely
shocked me and I want to share them with
you because I think they're just funny
interesting we as humans we have more
foreign cells in our body than human
cells everybody knows that right now let
me tell you something more interesting
than then um you know what makes us who
we are is not our genes but the genes
that are expressed right because the DNA
is simply the alphabet it is what is
expressed the RNA is really makes us who
we are because we all have identical
gene and every part of our body are here
is the same DNA that are thought there's
a reason why I don't have to it's
growing here and the hair growing in our
mouth it's gene expression that some
genes are under expressed over expressed
or not expressed is what makes us who we
are our human DNA only produces about
22,000 genes the microbes in our gut
produce two million to 20 million genes
that means at the most we are one
percent human they are if you look at
all the population of the human beings
on earth and you had five thousand earth
they'll still be less human beings than
the number of organisms in a single
human blood out of the two million or so
that the gene expressions in here how
many of them are bacteria versus one guy
for the forty trillion of them live
inside our 40 trillion of them we live
inside of that is a bacterial the the
bacterial viruses East fungus mold all
of them combined what approximate
proportion yes it is a large percentage
of them are bacteria but even the small
portion of them that are viral and also
the ones that I would say are phages two
of the viruses
that only in fact the bacteria they
don't in fact the humans cells they
infect the bacterial cells and those
fridges are very very important in fact
most people have never looked at these
phases the interesting thing that was
gonna point out was it turns out in the
last 10 years there is not a literary
scientific literature that talks about
every single chronic disease when I say
chronic disease whether you call them by
name Parkinson's Alzheimer's depression
anxiety obesity diabetes autoimmune
diseases heart disease cancer every one
of them they have one thing in common
it chronic diseases are caused by the
chronic inflammation and the chronic
inflammation is caused by the imbalance
of your gut so you don't take my word
for it just Google Parkinson's and
microbiome and it will show you that
Parkinson's he starts in the gut 15
years before you see it in your first
symptom Alzheimer autism in fact there
was a research that was published a
month ago that says the mother's
microbiome during pregnancy has a direct
effect on the chances of autism in the
kid so when mommy's pregnant they're my
mom's microbiome changes the autism
chances for the autism the kid now I
want to just give you a little bit more
interesting stuff that I learned from
just being in this space what I didn't
realize was that almost everything that
we eat today is first comes in contact
with the microbiome and they convert
them into nutrients that means the food
we eat is not the food that body gets
our human body is like a doughnut there
you tube that goes to in the middle
right
maybe the input and there is an output
there is a treat there right in between
are the gut organisms that are actually
taking that food converting them into
the nutrients that are absorbed in the
body our microbiome trains our immune
system so if you know 70% of all the
immune system is alone along our
gut lining 70% it trains all the stuff
so much so one would argue that our
organisms actually created us for their
own benefit and Ellen if you will
indulge me if I could tell the story of
how humans were created the is this more
of a hypothesis or how certain are you
about about this story this is a
tongue-in-cheek a story that has a full
scientific basis on it and I'll tell you
the scientific basis right after I tell
my tongue-in-cheek story so this is a
story that I always try to explain what
is these microbial and what are these
things are and people say if they can't
be inside us we should kill them all
what people don't realize is that our
human DNA is simply needed for us to be
born what keeps us alive are the gut
organisms without them we are actually
dead we cannot function so you imagine
circularity marriage is it well I don't
know about that what marriage you have
in this particular case they take
everything we do it for them so that's
the kind of marriage you have that you
have very happy so they're in they're in
control they're in control so let me
tell you how it all happens so I have a
story's called how humans were created
so close your eyes and now like a child
I'm going to tell you a bad side story
so we all know that algorithms is
started on this planet earth about 3.5
or 4 billion years ago you started to
see these amoebas and single-cell
organisms they've been around for
billions of years humans are only about
a couple of million years old
how did the humans come to be so here's
how I think all happened one day all the
organisms are getting together and they
all looked at each other and say see
we're sick and tired of living in this
small space we want to take over the
world and they all looked at each other
one of them said master I have an idea
what's your idea what if we can create
something bipedal
trillions of us could literally live
right inside it we can make it crave any
food we want and they're gonna run
around and find that food for us
all we have to do is keep this thing
healthy this bipedal thing is gonna go
all over the world he's gonna poop
everywhere it's going to spread us
around and he's gonna and we gonna take
over the world and they created humans
right after they created humans they
realized the problem just like today we
are worried about artificial
intelligence and we wonder what if
someday AI becomes is smarter than us
what's going to happen to us humans
these organisms are no dumb the
reassembled and say master master what
have we done aren't you worried someday
this thing we created called humans what
if they became is smarter than us what
are we gonna do about that master says
relax we took care of that problem
master what is the secret master says
remember inside their cell the human
cell this thing called they called
mitochondria they forgot it is one of
our bacterial brother right inside their
self
it is the bacteria that is inside the
human cell that supplies all the energy
to their self we sit here in the gut we
are constantly communicating with the
mitochondria anytime they go out of
control we shut the energy down they are
dead they better take good care of us
Master that's really brilliant but
you're not even thinking right now they
started to develop this thing called
brain what are we going to do about the
brain thing Master says that's the first
thing we thought about when we created
them how so master remember we all live
in the gut we put a direct connection
from the gut to the brain and they call
that a vagus nerve and they thought
they're going to name it after Las Vegas
thinking what happens in the gut is
going to stay in the gut they are so
wrong what happens in the gut goes
everywhere
in fact what makes them feel good this
serotonin thing we don't let them
produce much of that 90% of that we
produced it ourselves right here we
control their mood we even control their
behavior we control their amygdala we
control their prefrontal cortex but just
like a good leader we make them think
they are the one who are making the
decision we simply sit here we pull all
the strings and the puppet simply moves
so sit back relax we have taken over the
world and ladies and gentlemen that's
who we are we are simply the puppets for
these organisms
now in that tongue-in-cheek story let me
tell you the scientific basis now so if
you are really smart it will be the ones
that are helped being the puppet being
controlled by artificial intelligence so
what if they are the one who are
creating the artificial intelligence to
take control of us anyway going back to
it just google the article that was
published in the nature magazine three
months ago
how microorganisms use micro RNA
interference mRNA interference to
control our amygdala and the prefrontal
cortex for their own benefit think about
that for a second there is also a whole
study done on microbiome and
mitochondrial connection in Aging in
fact there was a study published this
morning on how they are able to
completely remove the wrinkles from old
mice by changing the mitochondria and
that mitochondrial function changed
simply by the microbial changing the
microbial so everything that I said it
sounds like something would be a science
fiction but that science fiction may
just be the truth that we are nothing
but a portable container for these
microorganisms and we are to large
extent
they're to spread them and be controlled
by them and any time when we don't take
care of them is what caused the diseases
what is the disease this is simply the
body not being at ease whenever we have
the imbalance on our gut our body
becomes uneasy is called dis ease this
ease is what we call disease our
pharmaceutical companies love people
being sick
our whole healthcare system is designed
to keep us sick I'm not talking about
communicable diseases by the way health
care system does an amazing job when you
have a communicable disease so if you
have infection or if you have an acute
need our health care system is perfect
it was designed for that just like our
education system what it wasn't designed
was for chronic diseases it was designed
for episodic sickness not for the
chronic sickness chronic sickness
happens when you have chronic
inflammation when you have a chronic
imbalance in the gut now imagine when
you have a chronic disease whether it's
a diabetes or obesity or pick a name you
want
no one cares why they don't want to look
at the root cause you have autoimmune
disease they don't try to figure out why
do you have autoimmune disease what do
you do to suppress the immune system
which is what the Humera does every
single autoimmune disease they suppress
the immune system and you ask the doctor
if you suppress the immune system
don't you think I'm gonna get a whole
bunch of other diseases oh yeah but we
got drugs for that so you take a drug
for one disease it causes three more
disease yes what happened they give me
drug for three more diseases now you
have 9 more diseases and by the time you
get old enough you're popping more pills
than blueberries that's a problem every
time you get chronic disease there is
someone out there in a pharmaceutical
company person sitting there say
catching
rest of the light they got a subscriber
they got a subscription business going
there your doctor makes money when
you're sick your hospital makes money
when you're sick your pharmaceutical
companies make money you're sick and
you're wondering isn't then the
insurance company wants to keep me
healthy because they they've making the
money when we are healthy it turns out
not so and here is why
insurance companies are regulated by law
now imagine by law they have to give 85%
of all the premium they collect back to
the policyholders if they keep the
policyholders hair healthy they have to
give the money back they cannot make any
more than 15% so if they keep you
healthy they make less money less
absolute money what do they learn let's
bring on more chronic diseases because
more they are more the premium the more
money they are making the cause they can
only keep 50% what is the ideal society
look like the ideal society looks like a
society that takes control of their own
health so what did the only person in
the health care business who doesn't
want to be sick who is that the person
who is sick what did we do we started a
company they say we are going to go
direct to the person who is sick we
going to tell them what is going on
inside their gut at a molecular level
and then we're going to tell them what
to do about it we're going to tell them
what foods they should be eating there
are good which going to tell them what
foods are bad for them what we learned
was very interesting there is no such
thing as universal healthy food Popeye
was wrong pop I thought the spinach was
good for everyone it turns out about
half the people his spinach causes more
harm than good and here is why his
spinach has very large quantity of
oxalic acid oxalate if you do not have
in your gut
the organisms that can detoxify oxalic
acid into
something benign that oxalate is going
to end up as a kidney stone or worse
cause other inflammation and that people
say oh that is fine but all of the
antioxidative stuff like pomegranate
juice raspberry almonds they got to be
good for everyone it turns out none of
these things actually have antioxidative
qualities pomegranate juice has
something called ellagic acid allergic
acid is not antioxidative allergic acid
if you have the right enzymes and the
peptides produced by your gut organisms
can get converted into something called
Uralic and a ula and you roll it in a is
what gives the empty oxidative
properties when it's absorbed in the
body majority of us cannot convert
allergic acid into you rollatini the
best you're doing is pissing off your
money are the worst it's causing the
inflammation in your microbiome is about
95 percent different than mine is and
for each one of us then I can process
maybe we care it's differently than you
do there's spinach differently
raspberries differently it's a so it's
very interesting our human DNA every any
two of us have 99% same DNA when it
comes to our microbiome less than 5% is
same now you see all this knowledge is
something you didn't create everyone
knows microbiome is important and some
of you may have done the microbiome test
before why is that the science has never
gotten there and the reason is the
science could never actually look at
what was going on inside your body in
your gut what the microorganisms were
producing and I don't I mean I don't
wanna go too technical but I'm gonna
just give you a basic idea of how far
the science has come and what is
allowing us to do it now and only us we
can do that and again you have to
understand I didn't start this company
because I want I need to make more money
you can just take my word for it that
there is nothing that I want
that I can't have so only reason I
dedicate my life to doing this is
because this is my way of giving back to
the society I came from nothing and the
Society gave me everything I have and
the only way I know how to give back to
the society is to do things that's gonna
make them make billions of people's life
better
so only technologies that were existing
was culture so people could culture this
tool and find out what bacteria were
there in that thing it turns out 70% to
80% of all the organisms that are inside
our gut are anaerobic that means as soon
as they're exposed to oxygen they are
dead so you could culture them so we
never knew what was there then came
about the technology called 16s 99% of
all the companies that are out there
doing the microbiome test they're
scamming you they use something called
16s so when you google and you see 16s
so companies like you know you buy
American gut project by on every one of
them just use 16s because really really
cheap 16s first of all can not detect
any virus fungus Eastern mold
even the bacteria it can only detect at
a genus level at a genus level every
human being on planet has the same
Genesis at a genus worried the genus so
if you asked me said Naveen you're from
India tell me the what's the genus of
India I would say well there are some
man there there are some woman there
there are some young people there's some
old people and you saw or the same as
America and it's yeah that's the same
but you know India has lot of crime and
you're telling me there are lot more
women in India woman must be criminal
and that's really what all you were
doing was saying oh you got more back
through a letís than Firmicutes boom
that's said but you don't say that a
genius-level it doesn't matter
he's so genus are man or woman his
species will be is it Paulo or is it
John is it Ellen strain will be what are
the functions they could be doing are
they entrepreneur the electrician what
is most important is not even that
what's most important
is what is that they're doing right now
what function are they performing are
they producing stuff that's good for you
or are they producing the stuff that's
bad for you
so some companies do something called
metagenomics which is DNA analysis DNA
only tells you what can happen
I think this parts so important that
you're teaching right now yeah just the
fact that there are different levels of
understanding something yeah yeah and
different businesses that do these
different sort of levels of
understanding this in itself can teach
us so much about how much are we going
in depth into understanding ourselves
surface level really deep isn't be good
I'm very amateur yes continue now I'll
say well that you know so DNA analysis
can tell you all the organisms at a
strain level what is the downside of
that every time we eat any food whether
it's a plant or meat all of the viruses
and the bacteria that's coming from
plant or food when you look at the
microbiome and the poop all of them show
up they're all dead we could be any last
for a long long time you see all the
false positive of all the DNA that
exists that may not be in your gut
second part is you still have no idea
what they are actually doing because
organisms hundreds of different
organisms can be producing the same
thing and that is the one of the problem
that used to happen people look at two
people and let's assume both are obese
right and you say this person has these
set of organisms and this person has
totally different set of organisms and
the both are obese or both are diabetic
it can't be the microbiome because
they're so different it can't be that
what they were missing was they didn't
realize they were all doing exactly the
same thing what causes obesity and what
causes the diabetes is inflammation and
if they're both producing the compound
called LPS lipopolysaccharide which is
highly inflammatory then it doesn't
matter what organisms are there you're
looking at what they are producing
and that is where the change happened so
here's how I ended up is starting this
company I was at Los Alamos National Lab
how many people know what loss almost
National Lab is famous for atomic bomb
they know how to kill people so even
though it was called Manhattan Project
it was not done in Manhattan I can tell
you that it was done at Los Alamos
National Lab in New Mexico in last a
town called Los Alamos they were working
on a bio defense technology trying to
figure out if a bad actor were to get
hold of something biological how would
we ever know what's making people sick
so they came up with a technology that
is able to look at any bodily fluid and
it can analyze the RNA of what organisms
are there and more importantly what are
they producing what enzymes are being
produced what peptides are being
produced what is going on inside the
body when they were describing this
technology how they do this biological
weapon detection and I said wow if I
know what's making people sick why can't
I just simply license the technology and
keep people healthy and that we
basically ended up getting an exclusive
license to this technology and I
launched Lyle and the beauty of the
things what I'm about to tell you is
that something you should do yourself
this is Merritt transcriptomics is what
mara transcriptomics is called RNA
analysis so you're getting a dynamic
view of what's going on what is exactly
the microbes are producing nobody can do
that
this took 2 billion dollars of
government money that means our taxpayer
money what I'm about to tell you is
something you guys should really try it
yourself which is you can go to NASA
every single government agency all the
technology that they have spend hundreds
of billions of dollars you have a right
to own that technology so I went to NASA
JPL they have an amazing sensor that can
detect is smallest faintest light and
tell you where that what that light is
coming from which is called Hubble
telescope right
a delta doh creamy sensor I saw that and
I'm thinking wow I was reading a you
know magazine and it was talking about
that how all bacteria have something
called autofluorescence
under under UV light that means if you
can shine a UV light on this at 120 to
160 nanometer it will shine a
autofluorescence at 300 320 nanometer
and I'm thinking wow why can't I just
use this tiny sensor with the camera and
anytime you're sick you spit and you
look at the camera and say you have a
bacterial infection take antibiotics so
you don't need the antibiotics anymore
that simple my point is you can go to
any of the stuff in any lab Lawrence
Berkeley Lawrence Livermore Los Alamos
cd-r any one of the lab and you can see
any technology you want you are a
citizen of this country you get to see
whatever you want and you can license it
and you don't have to pay much for it
and for you in fact if you're smart you
don't repay anything for it and that's
amazing I can you know give you a whole
bunch of things that I learned about you
know from the babies when the babies are
born people used to think they're
sterile in the sterilized in the room it
turns out they're not so
Amiata fluid has microbiome of the
mother placenta and so does the cord
blood the first time the baby is going
through the birth canal this is where
they exposed to the microbiome in fact
when the baby is born to c-section
it is completely deprived of the
microbiome that comes through the birth
canal and most of those children now you
will see they have allergies eczema a
whole bunch of other chronic diseases
and I'm not suggesting remotely that we
should never have c-section but people
who do c-sections simply elective in
China 50% of the baby is born or through
c-section because they believe if they
are born at a certain time of the day
and certain hours that has eight in it
it ate something it is really really
good for them and they do essentially
elective surgery without realizing what
they're doing to the baby in fact what
he surprised me really was
the breast milk not only has the
mother's microbiome coming through the
breast milk it also has the antibodies
but most importantly the first seven
days ten days of the mother's milk is
full of colostrum that cannot be
digested by the human body that
colostrum is only there to feed the baby
and microbiome babies microbiome that
cannot be digested by the human body can
only be digested by the microbiome and
they convert that microbiome because
it's all fibrous into a short chain
amino acids that are good for the baby
so imagine what nature is really telling
us I just created the offspring and only
way I can keep this office spring
healthy is not to feed it but to feed
them so novena I had yet volume I get
through this process of understanding
this dynamic state of my microbots I'm
coming back to the you know I'm here
talking about the company because really
you know to me is about imparting
knowledge I mean I don't want you to
think that I'm here to sell you anything
that just not what I want to do the
company that I started was simply for
simple reason I was tired of seeing
people sick and I really shared the
story one of the genesis was that my
father got diagnosed with the pancreatic
cancer and it is so obviously all the
research that shows that pancreatic
cancer happens when you gut microbiome
through leaky gut goes into pancreas
shuts down the immune system and allows
the cancer to go and
just don't know what to do I did real
early in that stage of to be able to
solve the cancer problem we even see
that now
whether the immunotherapy whether it
works or does not work depends when you
got microbiomes if he just google
immunotherapy and microbiome it will
show you that they have proven now that
they can predict when you do immuno
therapy but that is gonna work or not
simply looking at your gut microbiome I
you know my dad went through
chemotherapy and he was healthy and the
chemotherapy almost killed him he could
walk he couldn't talk he couldn't get up
from the bed i stopped his chemotherapy
and now it's going to be what's going to
be and I told my dad I said I don't know
if I can save you but I can promise you
something that I will make sure that no
one else suffers from that and what I'm
doing now is really just doing
everything I can to make sure no one
else suffers there is no reason for any
one of us to have a chronic disease ever
I mean there is no reason it's not
something you wake up in the morning and
you said you know honey I was out last
night I might have caught diabetes but I
might have caught obesity I might have
caught cancer it's not something that
happens overnight it happens over a long
period of time because you have a long
period of chronic inflammation and we
gotta understand that dynamic still is
it's shifting and then make the
predictions and so basically this thing
you know it's first of all you know we
didn't want to make it like a medical
kit so we made it beautiful so that you
know it at least looks like a product
that you would even after everything you
will keep the box it's beautiful if
nothing else for jewelry right in this
box is really simple I mean there is
another thread and you're my second
sample is it oops
and really inside there there is really
very few things there is basically a
toilet seat and it tests you and you
touch the you know toilet seat the poop
touch it put on the test you prepaid
envelope and you stand it and ten days
later you essentially have on your phone
everything that's happening inside
you've got what's the inflammation what
you digest is going on what's the matter
balloting going on every single organism
how activity
but most importantly we tell you the
foods that are bad for you and here's
very interesting there is not a day goes
by I don't get an email or a video from
someone that says you changed my life
people who have had joint pains for you
know 10 20 years that disappearing
there was an autoimmune rheumatoid
arthritis I have people who are saying
their acne is gone the eczema is gone
almost everyone is losing weight because
obesity comes from inflammation not
because you anything too much food we
have people who are now telling us about
you know acne eczema autoimmune diseases
and you know obesity diabetes couple of
people really shocked me one woman
posted on a Facebook and say my eyesight
improved and and three other people
jumped on it said me too I'm thinking
eyesight it turns out some of the
vitamin is being produced by the gut
lemma there is a vitamin A or vitamin D
something magical is happening here we
don't know all the things that are there
but we do know when we fix the leaky gut
and the inflammation magical things
happen and that's what the key is to fix
the leaky gut and the inflammation in
the gut and you analyze and tell them
this is what a really important change
in the way that you eat his food is a
medicine yeah so interestingly the
reason I'm willing to tell you the names
some of the names and these because they
sent us the testimonial that we put them
on our website now Reese knows Tammy
Lakes who is a head of digital for a
single University she tell me that she
has been sick for eight months throwing
up eight times a day and diarrhea went
to all the doctors everything and they
told her to start eating healthy and she
said there is nothing work nothing was
going on and hours of the board meeting
and this they told me say look I can't
believe you're telling me this thing
works I'm gonna try it and she told me
three weeks later all her symptoms
stopped and I said what happened what
did we do and she said you told me not
to eat spinach broccoli and corn I was
in a gluten-free diet eating corn and
they told me I was supposed to be eating
healthy and low carb so I was eating
broccoli and spinach and those were
exactly what was causing her all the
issues and just avoiding those three
foods is what caused her to get better
I have this one of my investors the bull
ventures in this case was it that inside
of her she could not process and causing
inflammation and then you're able to
tell what is inside that you cannot
break down or that is harmful free that
causes inflammation and what is actually
really good for you and what foods
you're eating and what food you should
not be eating and that simple right but
it looks at and now in the new version
that's coming out in two weeks every
food will tell you why so we no longer
the wudu magic you click why are you
asking me to eat ginger well here's why
why did you tell me not to need this and
then why making the ginger with a
specific microbe other things have too
much or too little or other things we
also did is very interesting we took
thousand people 1,000 people we put a
continuous glucose monitoring on them
and then we fed them 55,000 different
foods and we monitored can we predict
just by looking at the things that are
being produced in your gut what type of
glucose response so the glycemic
response you're going to get and it
shocked us everyone thought that things
like almonds are the best snack you pop
them in because they have no glycemic
response we found people who had ten
times of 20 times higher response and
almonds than bread and once we did
finish the study now we are able to
predict just by looking at your gut we
can tell you when you eat carrot what is
the group glycemic response to insulin
response you're going to get because
when you have too much insulin in your
body is going to cause inflammation
so we cannot predict just by on that
simply looking at you got we can predict
what food you is good for you and what
food is bad food right it is
unbelievable to me I never thought in my
life I'm going to ever get an email from
someone telling me that you change my
life and some of you might have heard my
podcast on Tom bill you about health
theory it's his wife who has been so
sick for eight to ten years and I was on
his podcast and he says at the end he
said you gave me my wife back
I will sacrifice a goat for you right I
never thought that she he thought I lost
and he said she's now back to normal
and I'm thinking me being a software guy
what are my chances of ever changing
people's life it's because I cared
enough to do it I cared enough to
dedicate five years of my life I say I'm
going to fix this problem interesting
thing is since we use lot of AI and
artificial intelligence in analyzing all
the data and you can imagine is our
second highest cost after sequencing is
Amazon Web service amount of data we
analyze it only can be done through AI
and you can imagine you know we now have
tens of thousands of people in the last
couple of months that have signed up and
we have massive amount of information
every time a person signs up not only
makes them better makes everyone before
them better and contributes to the
humanity going forward to everyone else
better every one of you who signs up
just know that once we have million
people signed up we will have all the
information we will need to be able to
solve all chronic diseases so I am here
to ask for your help
help us because I am NOT a market here I
don't know how to spread the word
someone here can help me if we can get
people to sign up and use the service we
make no money on it this thing used to
be five thousand dollars when we
launched we launched at $1,000 we reduce
the cost to 399 our cost came down to
$2.99 we now discount
by $100 you can buy there for $2.99 in
fact when you go to I don't know if your
code simulation gets you over so why I'm
calm slash simulation you'll get $100 on
if it's not working just go to why I'm
calm slash friend of me this is this is
really important you're you're taking
this initial conversation of moonshots
and you're looping it into this way of
you find something that you want to help
with the world with and as you go and
build that thing that helps make the
world a better place that then you rally
together these amazing responses that
you're getting from people about the
value that you're providing to them and
that's what creates not only a great
company but also creates something that
you can be proud of yeah someday we will
all have to look back in the mirror what
did we do with our life what did we do
that was meaningful that we gave that up
to the society and if even if you don't
do something on your own if you can help
be part of the community that helps
achieves that is really only we will do
it
pharmaceutical companies are relying on
the fact that human agents will never
come together we will never come
together and they know they'll can
continue to victimize us because any
time when we are sick we are helpless
and hopeless when we are helpless and
hopeless it's guaranteed someone is
going to victimize you and I health care
system will do that for us I was the
first person went on a CNBC when I
started this company and I said
pharmaceutical companies have become
parasite on humanity and I believe the
humanity will come together to kill this
parasite and that's what I'm asking
let's kill those parasites the fruit is
the medicine so by the way this is very
interesting we are talking about all
these science we talked about and here
is Alan what he's quoting his hypocrite
ease 2400 years ago he said treat he was
a doctor you know what he said all
diseases began in the gut then he said
one man's food is another man's poison
Spanish is not good for everyone right
and then he said let food be thy
medicine let thy medicine be thy food
that's it it took us billions of dollars
in all these advanced science to go back
to what we knew all diseases start in
the gut right so this you also work on
so much philanthropy not just the you
know the moonshots with with XPrize well
1 million dollar women's safety XPrize
that was just funded and that's um that
was amazing and just had a recipients
and then now the next iterations of
XPrize are looking great Naveen the work
and philanthropy the work in moonshots
work with microbiome the work with moon
express is all very inspirational